[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIEL OLSHANSKY: Hi, my name
is Daniel Olshansky.
I'm an Intern on the Android
team at Google.
And today I'll be talking about
some of the various
methods you can use to
animate fragments.
So today I'm going to discuss
a few different things,
including how you can animate
the switch between one frame
and another using fragment
transaction.
I'll talk about how you can
create animations via code
using object animators to
animate those fragments, as
well as a couple of very
useful call backs and
fragments that you can use to
create very custom animations
for your fragment transitions.
So jumping straight to the demo,
you can see here we have
just an image.
And this is a fragment that
only contains an image.
Tapping on it, it slides into
the background and pops up
another fragment.
So this here is just another
fragment containing text about
the Golden Gate Bridge, which
is our original image.
Tapping once again slides
that back out.
So looking at it once again,
tapping once slides it back in
into the background.
It has this dimming effect where
it darkens it and brings
up the text fragment.
And tapping once again slides
out the text fragment, dims
out that dark hover view,
and animates the image
fragment back out.
So jumping straight into the
code, there's a few different
things to note here today.
Firstly, there's some
boilerplate code.
We set up a click list in there
to switch the fragments
every single time we click
on the screen.
And in Switch Fragments, the
first thing you want to look
at is here.
So I create a listener, at the
end of which we're going to do
the actual fragment
transition.
So I start a new transaction.
And I call this method called
Set Custom Animations.
What Set Custom Animations does
is take in four animator
resource files that you can use
to animate one fragment
in, animate it out, as well as
when you're popping the stack
for the fragment transaction,
you can also pass the resource
files for animating the other
fragment in and out.
What you have to note here,
though, is that I am passing
in resource files for the text
fragment sliding up and down,
but I'm passing in 0s for the
image fragment that I'm
animating, because that's
a little more custom.
Then I add my text fragment onto
my stack, I set that to
null, and I commit
my animation.
So what this lets me do is later
simply pop my fragment
enter stack, and then my image
frame will come back up after
a text fragment is
animated out.
So all of this is done at the
end of an animation listener.
And if you go here to slide
back, that's where it's
actually going to
get executed.
So I set up a few animations
for the image fragment.
I'm going to rotate
about the x-axis.
I'm going to scale it so it
actually rotates in the
background and scales and it
comes a little bit smaller.
And what I'm actually going
to do as well is this
mDarkHoverView, which is just
a view with an opacity less
than 1 and a black background
color, it's going to fade in
over my image fragment.
So one of the things that you
can do with [? set cost ?]
animations is add animations
to other widgets or other
items that you have
on the screen.
Using this method, you can
actually add animations at the
same time as the fragment is
animated, except to things
that may be completely
separate from
the fragment itself.
Once I've set up all my
animations, I add a start
delay, such that what's actually
happening is after I
animate the image into the
background, only then will the
text fragment come back up.
And then at the end of that
animation, that's when the
fragment popping and transaction
actually happens.
So if you keep sliding back
down, there's a method called
Slide Forward.
And Slide Forward actually
gets called right here.
So what happens is, when you
click on the screen when the
text fragment is in focus, what
we're going to do is pop
the stack in order to
bring the image
fragment back in focus.
And when the back stack is
changed, we're going to call
Slide Forward.
And in Slide Forward, we're
doing almost the exact same
thing as what we did
in Slide Back.
We're rotating about the x-axis
back out, we're scaling
our image frame back up, and
we're fading out the dark
hover view instead
of fading it in.
All of this is then put together
using an animator
set, and that's how the
animation takes place.
So this is what you can do if
you want to have a custom
object animator and set
custom animations.
But the other important thing
that I really wanted to know
it was, in any fragment, there's
a callback method you
can override called On
Create Animator.
And the thing about On Create
Animator is it's a method that
gets called when you want to get
the animation object for a
fragment transaction.
It has a few usual parameters
you can use, but the key
behind this is that you can
essentially create any custom
animation you want here and
never be limited just to doing
things in an animated
resource file.
And then if we actually just
take a quick look at the
resource file that we passed
into Set Custom Animations,
they're right here.
We set up an object animator
with a From value, a To value,
a property name,
and a duration.
But one of things I did here is
I created a custom property
called Y Fraction.
And the reason I did this is
because unlike in older view
and twin animations, property
animations are independent of
what the container
actually is.
So if, for example, in twin
animations, you could tell a
view to animate from 0 to 100%
of its parent's width, we
cant' do this with property
animation.
And I found a workaround for
this by using Y Fraction.
So in text fragment, there's
a custom property--
sorry.
In Fractional Liner Layout,
there's a custom property
called Y Fraction.
And so what happens when you
create an Object Animator that
animates the property Y
Fraction, it's going to look
for a setter called
Set Y Fraction.
And given the setter right here,
Set Y Fraction, what I'm
doing is animating a float
value between 0 and 1.
But since in runtime I can
determine what the width and
height of my screen is, I can
actually just do some simple
arithmetic and animate it from
0 to some certain percentage
of its parent's container.
So those are some different ways
of animating fragments,
as well as a way to work around
not having percent
animations with Object
Animators, unlike you did in
older View Animations.
So I hope you enjoyed the
video, and thanks.